[Music]
let's go to
kelsey in columbus ohio hey kelsey good
morning how are you
hi i'm good how are you outstanding
what's going on how can i help
um well i have a four-year-old with my
ex
and um he recently moved to a different
state
and then filed for custody after not
really contributing
the last three years the custody
issue has really put a strain on me and
i'm
wondering how i go about maintaining my
mental health
through this while continuing
supporting my son and his relationship
with his dad yeah what a mess i'm so
sorry
what a mess um so first things first
is he gonna win custody it sounds like a
like a
like this isn't gonna go anywhere i mean
if he's got a back a history of
three or four years of not paying child
support and not being present
no one's going to take him away from you
to a new state unless you've got stuff
going on in your life
so tell me about the chances of him
winning this this custody suit
um the chances are low um
i never really necessarily worried
that he would win it's just
the whole mess of dealing with the
lawyer
dealing with the strain he's put on
everybody because it's involved you know
his whole family i have to get like
witnesses
and it's like the whole process
of it that is so mentally draining and
i'm also a full-time student
in college um so
it's it's the whole mental strain of the
whole process
that's really killing me awesome
i mean not awesome but i appreciate you
i appreciate you clearing
clarifying that for me um all right so
tell me about this little boy he's
pretty rad
yes he's awesome tell me about him
um so he's really funny he has a great
personality
his smile is magnetic everybody
seems to love him and think he's
hilarious everywhere we go
and he just is like a huge light in
everyone's life
so he's pretty fantastic
so you told me about how everybody else
feels about him how do you feel about
him
oh my gosh he's my whole world
um i love him so much everything i do is
for him
um and he's brought a lot of meaning to
my life so i mean i don't know what i
would
be without him awesome
so have you in the past struggle with
mental health challenges or is this
all new for you are you just feeling
overwhelmed all of a sudden
i've struggled for most of my life with
mental health
challenges like what
anxiety mostly depression
my family has a history of mental
illness too
so i've seen that all my life are you
actively taking care of yourself
i just started therapy last week which
is
really overdue but i'm glad that i
finally did it
good for you you deserve that your son
deserves that
and this life you're building together
is going to be um greatly facilitated by
you
by you taking that step take care of
yourself so i'm proud of you i know
that's hard
hard hard hard um so at the end of the
day
here's where you are okay and i know you
know this but i'm just going to say it
out loud and walk you through it
sometimes having somebody just
pull things apart for us pretty easy
pretty simply and just laying it out
there
can help a little bit okay so this is an
old saying you may have heard me say a
hundred times on the show
not by your hand but in your lap what
does that mean
that means that somebody just set your
house on fire
and you're in the front yard watching it
burn you didn't
like this match you didn't um
you didn't fill the house up with
gasoline somebody else did
it but now you're in the front yard and
you
have only one choice which is to go put
the fire out
right and so when i
am faced with a situation like this in
my life there's three things that i know
ultimately keep me well okay number one
is having other people in my life being
connected relationships
number two is really working hard to
control my thoughts which is what
therapy teaches you to do
and the other one is controlling what i
can control when it comes to my actions
right and at the end of the day that's
it
and what anxiety tries to do is
number one it's an alarm that lets you
know you're disconnected from other
people
right you're in a situation where you're
not safe or you're in a situation where
you feel out of control
right nothing would make me feel more
out of control than somebody who i used
to love and i used to trust
filing for a court order to take my
child away from me and move to another
state
that sounds terrifying i don't like my
daughter and my wife were out of town
recently
i don't like them my daughter being gone
a couple of days right
so can you honestly sit there for a
second and just put both hands down by
your lap and just go
somebody trying to take my kid away
just say that out loud
right now yeah right now just say it
someone's trying to take my kid away
okay
if that's not a um
that's not a good reason for your body
to sound the alarms i don't know what is
right so your anxiety in this moment is
warranted and it's right and it's good
it means your brain's working just fine
right
and then if you have an anxious brain
like i do you start dreaming about all
the scenarios all of the things
all of the what-ifs and could bes and oh
my gosh and then this is and that's
right
do you spin off and just head off into
the woods
oh yeah yes exactly and why do we do
that
because we're not gonna actually fight
or flee in real life we're just going to
do it in our heads
right and we're going to fight and flee
all over the place how many imaginary
conversations do you have with your
ex-husband that you'll never have in
person
um a dozen a day
does it solve anything ever no
it just makes it worse i know right so
much
worse okay so here's what you're gonna
do
you ready it's so simple
and super hard okay the first thing
you're gonna do is this
you're gonna get some people in your
corner do you have a friend there
your mom there besides a therapist you
have somebody you can trust
yeah you didn't you didn't answer that
very confidently
um no i do um my brothers are supportive
and
um my ex's family are actually really
supportive of me so
okay so let's lean on your brothers
because court is going to make them have
to choose and that's going to get messy
so i want you to reach out to your
brothers today and let them know
that you are taking some active steps to
be proactive and handle this deal
this custody suit is going to be a mess
they're going to want every text message
and email
and like you said witnesses there's
gonna be drama on top of drama on top of
drama
i want you to let them know you have
designated them
as the guys in your corner and you're
gonna call them at weird hours of the
night you're gonna send them text
messages that say it's all coming down
and their job is to write back and say
it's not and we love you
okay but let them know that they're
going to be your right or diet don't
just assume it
and two things are going to happen one
if they're good brothers like i know
they are they're gonna puff their chest
out and say yeah that's what's up
and your brain is gonna go okay we got
people
it's gonna check that mark off right
and then the second thing is i want you
to begin making a daily list this is
something what you do every day
of what are the things you can control
today
right okay the things that are spinning
out in your head
write all that write it all down but
you're gonna go down that list and say
what can i control today
so you might write down he might um this
is a list of your fears sorry i should
have said that your fears your anxieties
i want you to write all that stuff down
get it out of your head
on a piece of paper not the computer
either by the way number one they'll
subpoena that but number two
there's something kinetic about writing
with your hand it gets
tiring it's frustrating it's it's it's
it's you get mad when you're just
writing and writing
but i want you to write down a piece of
paper this guy is trying to take my kid
can i control that nope he's trying
number two i have to get all this
paperwork done
can i control that yep i'm just gonna
put on a to-do list and just get that
done i'm not gonna
be anxious about it i'm not gonna fight
it that's a thing i can do i'm gonna
i can control that i'm gonna move on
number three an old friend of mine is
now dating this guy and they move to
whatever
now i'm just making this stuff up
because it's my show and that's kind of
fun for me
you can write down i can't control that
right number four
i love my son and not a day will go by
that he doesn't know that he's the most
important thing that ever happened to me
can i control that yep
i'm exhausted can i go exercise and then
go to sleep can i control that
yep i'm feeling lonely and starting to
spin out can i reach out to my friends
can i control that
yep i got a crap ton of homework to do
can i control that
yep right and so what you're going to do
is you're going to slowly start
dwindling down all these crazy thoughts
that are spinning like a saw blade in
your mind
to just a list of a few things that you
can control and most of them are going
to be about you taking care of yourself
taking care of your body taking care of
your head and knocking these tasks
off and then the final thing is you're
going to work with this counselor
on how to begin to control your thoughts
and i'm looking at you
i can't see you but i'm looking into
this camera here i
promise with practice you can begin to
control your thoughts
sometimes my wife laughs me because
laughs at me because i'm walking through
the living room and she'll just hear me
go nope
and she'll just smile because she knows
i just had an intrusive thought pop in
my head about a worst case scenario
thing that could happen or not happen
and i just say nope and then i
immediately have another go-to thought
like that time my kid did a funny thing
or how much i love my folks
or that time me and my brother were
messing with reindeer on a cruise
whatever the thing happens to be
i've got things ready to go and over
time you begin to practice and you take
more and more ownership of your thoughts
and then that
those times when the depression kicks in
and you think this is my fault this is
always going to be this way
then you've got this new reservoir of
strength in your mind that says
no it's not and let's go exercise no
it's not
let's go call my brother we're going to
go for a walk no it's not i got one more
paper to write and then i'm done for the
semester
no it's not
i'm gonna go grab a couple of
girlfriends from my class we're gonna go
get some coffee
and with depression you take those
little steps with anxiety
you reach out with anxiety you write
down what you can control and not
control the anxiety
you begin to work on controlling your
thoughts
and suddenly you're going to look up in
a year this suit is going to be
dismissed on its merits it's a waste of
time
or they're going to go through the rig
meru and make sure that he never does
this again
you're gonna you're gonna have more
strength
you're gonna be well you're gonna be
have connection you're gonna be
graduating
and then honey your whole life is ahead
of you and you're going to take those
bricks out of your backpack and you're
going to pave a road that you and your
kid are going to walk on
and the people you never have met before
going to walk on
that's what redeeming all those pains
looks like man this is legacy this is
you building a road moving forward
but it starts with man getting connected
controlling what you can control letting
the other crap go
and then doing the hard work of
practicing practicing practicing
controlling your thoughts thank you so
much for that call kelsey